une nouvelle catégorie de clients pour
cette officine de la banlieue de tunis
habitué à délivrer des médicaments les
voilà depuis le 16 août invité à
participer à la campagne nationale de
vaccination au même titre que l'armée
tunisienne une invitation qui concerne
60 % des 2300 pharmacie que compte le
pays les pharmaciens sélectionnés se
voit alors délivré par le ministère de
la santé un protocole strict objectif
encadrer seront forts dans les normes
imposées par l'organisation mondiale de
la santé nous nous sommes mode depuis
longtemps des pharmaciens en chercher à
aider
le pays
devance cette pandémie qui existe chez
nous depuis un certain moment et qu'elle
crée vraiment de grands dégâts au sein
du conseil de l'ordre des pharmaciens
on a discuté souvent pour avoir une
participation effective des pharmaciens
tunisiens à cette campagne après une
inscription préalable sur la plateforme
et vax les citoyens depuis le 40 ans
reçoivent une confirmation de rendez
vous pour se voir inoculé dans la
pharmacie la plus proche une dose du
vaccin britannique astrazeneca une
campagne complémentaires qui connaît
depuis son lancement un succès auprès
des formations depuis que l'annoncé a
été faite que les vaccins étaient
disponibles dans les pharmacies j'ai
reçu vraiment au minimum une centaine de
coups de fil par jour pour pouvoir se
faire vacciner bon on est obligé de les
reporter à chaque fois au niveau 2 les
vagues pour leur inscription et pour la
pratique de l'injection une fois qu'ils
que ses programmés par devax la personne
qui viendrait les somistes
systématiquement à un petit
questionnaire sur la beauté soir lui
voit sa température aussi bien sûr pour
vérifier
qu'elle ne porte pas de gants n'a pas de
fièvre qui a pas de petits problèmes et
en pratique la vaccination et la
personne attend un quart d'heure le
temps de
de voir qu'il n'ya pas eu d'effets
secondaires immédiat chaque semaine un
grossiste livreur assure gratuitement à
livraison du sérum britannique afin de
permettre au plus grand nombre de
pouvoir être vacciné le plus rapidement
tout comme mehdi ils sont des dizaines à
se présenter chaque après midi pour
recevoir gratuitement leur première dose
un soulagement alors que le pays connaît
une accélération de sa campagne
vaccinale j'ai été convoqué il ya deux
semaines j'ai pas pu aller parce que
j'étais pas là donc et après quand ils
ont ouvert les pharmacies donc j'ai fait
hier et je ne retire aujourd'hui droite
c'est important pour moi c'est important
pour tout le monde parce que je me sens
vacciné faut quand même que le monde
ouvre quand on peut en sortir
normalement couvre normalement donc que
panasonic d'autres solutions après
l'armée qui a commencé à vacciner la
population il ya quelques semaines le
président de la république avait déclaré
que les pharmacies privées pourront
également contribué à la campagne de
vaccination qui s'est accélérée grâce
aux nombreux dons de doses venus des
quatre coins de la planète le pays qui
tente de sortir de cette nouvelle vague
meurtrière comptabilise désormais près
de 627 1000 cas de contamination et plus
de 22 mille morts est lié au virus
depuis le début de la pandémie